your doctor may obtain a liver biopsy to
determine the cause of liver disease and
the extent of the damage the liver is
located in the upper right abdomen just
under the diaphragm
it lies almost entirely within the
ribcage which provides some protection
to the organ the liver is critical for
digestion and metabolism it's many
functions include producing bile which
is necessary for fat absorption
producing proteins from amino acids
packaging fat for storage or
transportation in the blood regulating
blood sugar levels and processing
substances such as alcohol and drugs a
liver biopsy may be ordered to determine
the cause of abnormal liver function
tests
swelling or enlargement of the liver and
jaundice the yellowish discoloration of
the skin and white of the eye that
develops when the serum bilirubin is
elevated bilirubin is normally
metabolized by the liver these signs and
symptoms may be due to a variety of
liver conditions including cirrhosis
hepatitis
or cancer
before the procedure and IV line will be
started and you may be given a sedative
to help you relax a liver biopsy is done
with local anesthesia so you will be
awake during the procedure you will be
asked to lie on your back with your
right arm above your head you will need
to lie as still as possible during the
procedure the right lung and gallbladder
are close to the liver and moving could
cause damage to these organs your doctor
will determine the location of your
liver by ultrasound or by lightly
tapping your abdomen with his or her
fingertips after cleaning the area over
the biopsy site with an add a septic
your doctor will inject a local
anesthetic to numb the skin and surface
of the liver once the skin is numb your
doctor will make a small Nick with a
surgical blade this is where the needle
will be introduced your doctor will
carefully advance the biopsy needle to
the surface of the liver your doctor
will then ask you to hold your breath
while he or she advances the needle into
the liver and obtains the tissue sample
as soon as the biopsy is obtained you
will be able to breathe normally
you may feel a momentary sensation in
your right shoulder during or just after
the biopsy some patients have pain that
requires additional medication which is
provided by your doctor if needed
afterward pressure will be applied at
the site of the biopsy to stop any
bleeding and a bandage will be placed on
the incision you will need to lie on
your right side for a minimum of one
hour following the biopsy
after the procedure your blood pressure
and heart rate will be closely monitored
after lying on your right side for an
hour or two you'll be asked to lie on
your back for a minimum of three
additional hours liver biopsies are
considered outpatient procedures if
there are no complications you will be
discharged four to eight hours after the
procedure